Jacklyn or no longer takes out her
yellow vest to protest she was one of
the founders of the yellow vests
movement but now she's moving on at age
51 she's founding a political party Liz
I'm out wrong or the emerging ones the
goal is to fight for greater social
justice and equality the samantha has
continued this week I'll continue to do
my part we have to develop a network
across the region it'll be a lot of work
a multi for now the party headquarters
are in her kitchen
the story's on but also there's no time
for lunch you've all spends the
afternoon coordinating with supporters
and dealing with legal questions
she's a composer but her face is known
across France as one of the leaders of
the yellow vests me kiss but what's the
money for her YouTube video against
president Emanuel my corns fuel tax
hikes went viral and stirred up the
yellow vests protests but now she says
it's time to move on it was what we all
need olive p.m. the movement has reached
rock bottom it's becoming nonsense
they've radicalized and now these people
think they owned the whole yellow vests
movement no one can own me or hold me
hostage
Rojo Tasha move aww isn't alone and
denouncing the yellow vests more than
10,000 people took to the streets of
Paris their message to the yellow vests
that's enough they feel increasingly
alienated from the movement it's the
first rally in months that's for the
government
repository 21 million people voted for
the president defending freedom and
democracy a big reason damaged
infrastructure and trade also hurts
people back in more Wars village in
Brittany many people's support her
rejection of violence and also back her
party that's critical of the government
I think it's a moderate and constructive
way to propose ideas but they don't want
to get rid of the president we believe
it's better to deal with the current
government and try to improve things
rather than to kick them out war aims to
stand in upcoming local elections she
wants to play a different political tune
than Macomb our brothers bureau chief
max Hoffman is in Paris where fresh
protests I expect today Maxo as we heard
in the report one of the prominent
people involved with a yellow vest
movement now wants to form a political
party what will this mean for Emmanuel
macron what might sound strange but it
could help him for the European
elections in the beginning the yellow
vests were proud not to be affiliated
with any party but they did draw some
supporters especially from the far-right
for example from the Assam lemon Asuna
from marine lepen so if they now found
their own party there is a possibility
that they will take some voters away
from those right-wing parties like that
Assam blow monsoon ah now in the polls
up until now for the European elections
the far-right seemed to be in the lead
ahead of a minor in McCall's
or mash party but if it really is the
case that the yellow has found these
parties and they get some votes from the
far-right then it could mean that in
mind where Michael and his party might
come out on top during the European
elections something that the LRS
probably did not intend to do in the
beginning meanwhile a modern macro is on
an honest town
whole trip in a bid to connect with
people so what does he achieved so far
with that
Arita in the past he really focused on
the rural regions where a lot of people
feel disconnected from the urban centers
as you know France is a very centralized
country but now as of Monday he's
focusing more on the rural areas for
example the suburbs of Paris and what
he's trying to do is to reach out to
people make them believe that he really
is listening to them and he's no longer
pursuing this more well top-down
approach that he had in the beginning
that many people thought was completely
inappropriate so that's one part of what
he's trying to do and really it's hard
to say we know that the yellow vests
reject that approach they reject that
national debate but it seems that is
resonating with some people especially
with the elected officials that he's
talking to but it's hard to measure
these things so we can't really say at
this point how successful this whole
campaign is and Max as I mentioned a big
strike is planned for today what can we
expect to see it's going to be really
interesting because we have to see how
these different movements really
converge we have the biggest or one of
the biggest unions that call for this
general strike that will start around 2
o'clock local time but some yellow vests
have said that they want to be
affiliated with that the first time that
the yellow vests and the union's
converge in the past some yellow vests
rejected the union's we don't really
know what the turnout will be some say
it's up to 200,000 people that would be
quite a lot especially here in Paris but
like I said the yellow vests are
reaching a crucial point where some
people here say you know this movement
has run its course it's time to stop and
now how they reinvent themselves will be
crucial also for the president right max
Hoffman in Paris thank you very much
you